workshop introduced the team
[Music]
security consultant
project and then you know
the Bonneville and newer
development so first the Mozilla work
thing is a software that why they use
the same work
privacy
so the devil for today
talk about the IOC and
you can visit the website I didn't want
a lot of poor so that you can know a
little bit more about it and you have
the Flyers here that explain more about
it and then we're gonna move for the
microcosmic
and motherhood
so as part of the last mission to keep
the web open and say they created the
world engage awake which is a framework
and software that provides a useful
open-source web things and private
security you can use a lot the IOT in
the smart world can someone give us
examples about the smart case that they
usually use within their work like a
thermostats yeah other
you can use it anyone is working on the
IOT so here we're gonna give some
example about the smart homes and
especially for the LED lights the
sensors that are for monitoring the
distance sensors and that you can use
every day to make your home smarter and
this is the example we're gonna give
today and what's different about what
the last Mart home is that the typical
vendor has your IOT the data on an IOT
cloud
whereas for Mozilla for us there is no
data and you create your own user name
and password for the canoe canoe
okay so all you need for this you need
the Raspberry Pi which you will have
here for us in this workshop we're not
going to ask everyone to create their
own username and password so you will
have passwords that are here preset on
the other tables but later you can use
your own and you can download it from
the website you go to IOT dot
mozilla.org and you can download and you
have the micro SD card where you can use
it to create your own gateway and for
the web domain you can create your own
but now we're going to use this one
again
okay and the work things and syrup
opportu bility is with everything for
the ZigBee wave and bluetooth and then
you can also it's an open source
community development you can go to
github and you can join the conversation
you can join the code and you can work
with us on the mozilla iot and now a man
is gonna explain about the things get
away and what type of sensors we can use
and how we can work
cute
okay so hi again I'm Mel so this is
basically what you will see after you
configure your Raspberry Pi the first
picture shows the different sensors that
you have configured we will we will do
this hands-on today there's also an
option to upload a floor plan if you
have it in your home so you can see
which room has what sensors you can
create rules so when when it's 6:00 a.m.
turn the lights on or just expand turn
the lights off and this little fox is an
experiment so far it's a voice command
so you can either type turn the lights
off or you can tell him to turn the
lights off and it will respond so as we
said it's it's without a middleman you
own your own data it's pretty cheap to
set up all you need is a Raspberry Pi
for the Gateway and then sensors you can
either buy sensors there are plenty of
add-ons for interrupts lip
interoperability or you can create your
own sensors
okay so in order to examples of MCU
boards that you can buy I have them here
this is the circuit playground Express
and this is a microbe it has anyone
worked on this before yeah
okay
so they're pretty useful for educational
purposes because so this one has a LED
matrix that can be used as a screen it
has a motion sensor this one has a
temperature sensor knio knio LEDs and
they can be programmed using micro
blocks and I'll show you how
so this is our microblogs work so it's
it's an IDE if anyone is familiar with
scratch coding it's just a blocks it's
really simple practically anyone can
learn to use it it's transformed into
byte code and each each MCU has its own
a small virtual machine that runs on it
and it can run the code that is created
with micro blocks so now I'll show you
the the gateway and micro blocks
okay
that's what
so we have five raspberry PI's scattered
each one has a subdomain
so this one is JSS to dot Mozilla that -
IOT both org each one has a paper next
to it so you can check which one it is
so this one was created beforehand but
if you if you bring it if you buy your
own Raspberry Pi you can flash the SD
card with with the Gateway image that
you can download and then you create
your own credentials so I'll just go
here GSS -
but sure okay
you can allow notifications because
you're the one who's going to create the
notifications so there's nothing that's
coming from outside so this is the menu
this is where your things show up these
are where you make the rules the floor
plan the settings and
this is the smart assistance
okay
so let's add our first device so this is
Mike roblox I did a small circuit here
it's just node MCU and the LEDs so I
know the MCU
is
has anyone worked on this before yeah
one person okay so note MCU is a Wi-Fi
module so if you can turn pretty much
anything into an IOT enabled device
because it's connects to the Wi-Fi and
it gets assigned an IP address so what
I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna connect
this leads to to my IOT gateway mother
for my hammer who knows what was that so
I'm gonna open an example and what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna add
so it's 14
- so when I click connect
I can see the port so I connect this to
my USB and I can see the port that I
connect to come to e so here I'm gonna
write the network name so the thing that
I'm programming should be on the same
network as the gateway so the Gateway is
connected to a Wi-Fi called Mozilla it's
not the same Wi-Fi as your laptops Wi-Fi
so I'm gonna write the credentials
and I'm gonna start so as you see I get
an IP address that's assigned to me so
what I'm gonna do is go back here and
add a device
so I will add by URL and I will write
the IP here
what's happening it's the dream
[Music]
so don'ts don't connect them just yet
just follow follow along with me and
then we'll have plenty of time to do
hands-on
[Music]
yeah so so I added the IP address and
then I'm gonna call it the red LEDs
so now I have the red left hopefully you
can see it it's off and and I can turn
it on so now I can i i'm only connecting
it for power so i can disconnect this
completely
and it will still work so all you need
is just to click start on micro blocks
and it's permanently stored on your
device connects to all your recipe
yeah so this is but more about
microbots you don't have to just use it
for IOT you can use it to program as we
said the other MC use so this
sure
whatever
a little unit runkelman
so I'm gonna connect
okay I'm gonna open an example gonna put
Harry Potter
[Music]
to change something
this is the down this we can go to micro
club
yeah so that you can use this
and if you connect to the Wi-Fi
mobile
honey on the finish
okay
so does everyone have internet access
yeah so just go to microblog that's fun
and go to download links
yeah
around Oh No okay
okay so now just take the the node MCU
and try to connect it to two micro
blocks and let me know if there are
problems
what's that you have
interesting
and the mishmash
I'll add drama special this one's not
working
does it have a micro blocks oh no you
have to flush it in this area install
now get your share
we had eleven oh yeah
we're using the the other one but I
think it's time this is us this is the
32 yeah
okay are you happy to use that
let me try to flush it
oh yeah I'm going to connect
this are you I have to want that you
gave me but I also have this one which
is like Schubert actually this one has
multiple
oh whatever I mean like you can just
flush it Wow I'll keep that on try this
oh yeah you can test with this you need
the wire
[Music]
the non-autonomous is down the connect
mother for example battalion a machine
you know hello like you know
you shot it
so for the ones who connected just go on
I'll model IOT
yeah yeah so just just open hello hello
lens okay
so after you open hello lead just right
in the Wi-Fi Mozilla and password
Mozilla web things
Mozilla website
yeah so here was a lot
okay but okay I have you connected you
have a driver problem
did it little light up when you can I
saw it late coming up at this
[Music]
okay so you have to download a driver
can you go to Michael bucks of fun
[Music]
can you okay members
is it working
they show up yeah my communes drivers ok
what's the driving just Google know them
see you driver oh okay
yeah
No so you don't have any I have one yeah
okay so open hello ility and connected
starving yeah so this one actually
doesn't so this is an older uh-huh so
you won't see it unless you go
Oh
there's a lot Mozilla where things just
wasn't our friends the driver did you
did you know the driver or did it work
just myself okay
I usually mask
something was happening nice
anyway they're working with
so you're not talking cereal we're
talking through Wi-Fi
no we're talking cereal but I need to
get an idea
yeah
muck we can't see where do we get to
drive
so it just Google know them to you
driver Mac okay maybe it was a year to
part from the Wi-Fi for this I think
it's you
do you want to switch yeah I don't know
I think it depends on this one so
this is what we do yeah I know so you
driver yeah yeah okay I think you'll
find it in American situation improved
I mean that'll work too
what are you talking about hmm do you
know the burger no but it should out
here there we go nationals MC air driver
mark I will have a pitcher
ah
that's terrific
yeah did you did you download this
writer
so just know them see you driver back
yeah yeah
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
does it work
that's it work
yeah so don't go to Los Angeles gonna
try Mozilla and Mozilla web things
and click on stop and start
okay so like I have this IP address go
to your browser
go to JSP denial
okay yeah Plus and I add by URL and
right right the IP address
now you can't copy you can click here
4301 seven
forty-three about 70
submit
[Music]
okay so here you can name it change the
name just name it something you would
recognize okay yeah
so this is your left so it doesn't have
a leg so it's not gonna do anything
something so yeah I have actually one
other report and the lads so we can
connect to it but can you can you let
the others try and so what does it do
so it's just now it's connected to the
what do you have a break for an hour you
know we can yeah so I'll know I'll bring
you anything
yeah I'll bring the breadboard and
energy but but it's successful so now
it's so you can you can even access it
from your mobile right yeah same
Hey
so you can even you can even oh no no
you can't because you're not on the same
network but if you're if you're
connected to the same network you can
write the IP address of this and you can
see the other JSON
-
I'm a vegetarian
Mozilla website
Menma nom nom University
they were getting a problem in doing the
burger man was a peasant mismanage Oh
what do you call it the check something
oh yeah I'm guessing it's universal
network at night okay
yeah I mean we can try using the Mozilla
Wi-Fi yeah they can get yeah yeah Nikki
so I wrote down the connect
I love talked about Kassala how there
was a chocolate connecting dr. Dominic
wasn't Mahatma's
mahasabha food I had a hot a low
connected al-assad oh no a little
nervous
oh I don't know yeah yeah so no one was
able to download the driver install it
anyway despite than this massive guy
okay did it like [ __ ] yeah we're good
why does it work I don't know red light
is that a good thing
I yeah but it doesn't say so I'm still
not serious
[Music]
so show us the sound again
[Music]
did the brew work or did you get an
error we failed
staining for everyone
yeah
all right just
so Mike they're there now you'll dig
without this room just this silikal nuts
yeah you can download it without the
blue Camaro there's the damage father
yeah the ruby one just as hi labs
yeah
[Music]
just wanting for people using Mac if you
are not able to see the comport you
probably need to download the Silicon
Labs driver
sorry
so yeah
so this is too large I'm gonna keep the
part outside so the grounds here yeah
yeah you need
a wire so d5 is actually GPIO 14 yeah so
if you go here
okay go to attendance
said digital still you drag it and you
put it under no yeah here so digital pin
14 to fire those drag it over the green
thing get a wire for you
would you even know
mr. Callender
I don't think so
[Music]
the unique creativity
did you rerun the code because we
changed it no because the the Gateway is
connected to the Mozilla network so we
cannot use this directly connected a no
so so the sensors and the Gateway should
be on the same subnet oh but you can but
you can ask yeah so this one should be
almost Allah because this one is a
Mozilla but you can access the page from
any network yeah
the URL is equality
yes yes
actually this one yeah yeah okay yeah
but this one you can access it from any
network
of the public
didn't work come on I can't see anyone
getting working this micro didn't LEDs
like it's is there an array of LEDs like
that on this device what is it
the LEDs yeah mr. vice different this
one yeah no it hasn't arrived like that
oh no this the micro bit LEDs is
different but all where are they running
the lens oh yeah so if the device is a
microbe eclair that will do this evening
acts it will do this or not it will just
write up the integrated market but I
can't see anyone getting a working yes
so some of them are actually getting it
working but I just want to check if the
people with a driver problem yeah it
didn't work didn't it
yeah
watch this already edit is it the same
IP address yeah okay so it probably need
to I did it yeah
thereby URL
there's two models of vases yes the
larger one is the one that's working
without a driver
oh it's a smaller one with a flavor
troubles really so that's that's strange
yeah this is the older one have you
tried giving the larger one to the
people who are having trouble yeah I
think so let me complete yeah
okay
sorry
disconnect so yeah
today I'm not doing this one how I just
like theories how do we prove it but we
known each other
it's it's already uploaded so now I'm
disconnected oh yeah completely
disconnected
it's just connected for the power and it
still works
so you can disconnect it and connect it
to a power I just confirmed it yeah it's
working the large one that's the larger
work work okay that's good no actually
we have more larger than small ones okay
so we can stir yeah we can switch them
up
yeah so did its work did not work it
didn't work it was connected Wi-Fi
connected but LEDs in turn on this one
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this this one
doesn't have an easy to turn on oh yeah
it's working as long as you can connect
it to the Wi-Fi we can so these guys are
trying with the LED so when they're done
I can because I only have a copy of
breadboards okay
sorry we'll be saying that this one
doesn't have one everything so that if
they try to yeah but if you want you can
connect to my energy it's on let me
check on which one
yeah give me your my MCU yeah yeah he's
gonna try so if if you go to jss to dr.
Mozilla Oh
mozilla - IOT that work
[Music]
okay
and them oh yes a dot-com
workshop workshop it's okay
so they just yeah they just disconnected
it so if you want to get sure
just give it a moment to connect
[Music]
is it great out
okay can you clip
[Music]
working there
[Music]
that's not
yes I think it's not connected to the
internet yet but we can we can actually
do it with you yeah
okay okay you need to add go to pens did
you put it here yeah the discipline is
14 and then go to variables and take on
put it instead of the green thing yeah
okay now I'll connect
okay
yeah
you should pop up with the IKEA
what
so does it takes a lot yeah
what's
[Music]
can you try it again
stop
before this one yeah quickly I'm not
sure why it's not working yeah well yeah
maybe there's too many connections
the only age of Isis
just replug me mm-hmm
my car down
let's see
it's correct
okay okay okay okay so let's go to the
browser
[Laughter]
[Music]
so this connects to your local network
and they only the expressway partner or
whatever the what this yeah so the
Raspberry Pi is it's configured on your
home network and all the sensors are
also on your home network but this page
you can access it from anywhere okay
houses software on the resident allows
it to cockatoos
[Music]
disconnect and even when you're in
disconnected the code the code is
already on the device so it's still
worth flashing once and after so it's it
still works it works
I don't know what it's supposed to still
work all right
I'm gonna take this
is this working no it doesn't you might
not recognize the device you want to try
this you could try
samyama she must've understood like the
blue china shop
this one's working yeah yeah apparently
the oldest devices working this is like
the VD 0.1 okay but but
[Music]
the head did brick you drive it when
support lazy
now the other one the one that I
borrowed that's a lot so the small ones
working we this guy can get it working
so am I get him to help me with some
other people okay
yes pretty Jerusalem yeah they are two
eighty six years old at this one the
small one it's not working with other
driver but this one's working without
the drivers yeah yeah it's working
no but it did a burger this one or this
one
maybe it's like baby baby so so this one
breaks yeah okay so disclaim yeah
so this is the same good
I'm indicate oh no it's it's I think
it's this it's this is a basketball
no but that one no this one no no [ __ ]
I also try to be this one of this
horrifying for me
yeah yeah wait what yeah so maybe we're
using another know them to you they
small no wonder you tried no this one
this one was with with Mike okay so what
words I don't want to go but you can you
can use in there okay can I take this is
there anyone having that you're not
getting an idea
[Music]
so this is a natural problem I think
I'm here it oh this is your idea okay no
you don't see anything because it
doesn't have a light but you can see it
can did you go to
Jess oh yeah
yeah which was a jazz for okay so now
you go to add by URL and you write the
IP address
yeah you can't copy others just a second
she's gonna pass this naked Amanda city
in non-dollar know that she was really a
mountain Chalet Kiera okay so this this
is the device so you're not in actually
going to see anything because it doesn't
have a light but it's now connected to
the this is the same yeah but I
connected a light to it so you can try
with this just go to get connected and
go to
okay
so we need to change
so this is connected to pin 14 its
okay forty-three underage
[Music]
1 9 2 or 6 843 to two weeks
don't know
batrider cold-hearted the end quote so
there's no additional breakfast no
there's no addition they I have to
breadboards actually where's the second
one so what you're asking is is can you
put it on a private cloud instead of
yeah so it's connected to then so right
now no but it's connected to the
Internet but it's not storing your data
outside so your data is on the Raspberry
Pi okay
stopped can click stop stop okay so go
to pins okay
the third one said did you convince yeah
the closest doesn't matter
so drive accepted it up in here yeah
above yeah okay
so digital pin 14 then go to variables
variable
yes
and drag on ya drag it over the green
thing ya know I don't know what way you
were first yeah yeah here yeah okay now
start okay I'll connect
the closest
okay yeah so this is your IP you go to
its you can click here to say IP address
okay
you can't copy it just I have to time it
yeah so go to the gateway to a browser
yeah this one yeah the one that you're
dragging yeah that's fine yeah so this
is the red left click on it off it's off
right okay like a cutter head on a sweet
awesome settle for Tim we thought the
uncommon
does does anyone have any problem
does anyone have problem is everyone
gone is it what's that it is anyone not
done is anyone gone
what's done
[Music]
yeah yeah can you just check if
everyone's okay so we can start with
multiple yeah yeah what's up so trying
this right now this is the Wi-Fi oh but
but you know you know you just need to
connect this here
[Music]
I think it's nice there's a lot of
people that are connecting to my
Oh your password is wrong
stop it
maybe
I think my intimacy
it's difficult to tell whether it's now
it should be fast so if it's working
and here you can click and you can see
this guy knows how to install the driver
the works with a small one ok great so
what was the secret he knows how to why
why isn't it working
it's the shixin so basically yeah it's
the homebrew the checksum is really
outdated so you can just eat it the cat
fall and okay
by the way can in is the transport for
immersive a network because yeah yeah
it's correct but I'm having a lot of
devices connecting to it let's see if I
can kick someone out oh yes
yes
oh so it's a hot spot on your mobile so
that might be the problem because a lot
of people's right yeah how can I kick
someone out I can't kick someone out
now it's gonna mess everything up
I think I can disconnect the rice price
okay so you have an idea when I 22 so
now you know did you open the jail
is everyone okay mean by the marble is
like ten minutes so it's not gonna lie
to me because it doesn't have a little
and like yeah you can you can try this
actually this is already programmed so I
don't know to reprogram it harshly to go
to jss to
come on
it's the same demo at
workshop
I almost let this is
so what I think
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you want me
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
applause - white back here
[Music]
one you know sure
[Music]
yep
so now you kind of feel that the IOT
development is mostly about like trying
to figure out how to get yours you get
your things working and setup and
drivers installed and that's pretty much
the hardest part and you saw that key
with micro blocks you can just use this
kind of scratch kind of interface that
just pull together some some basic IOT
applications connect your Wi-Fi and even
use that device to serve as like a
makeshift home automation device you
know make it a light switch or something
like that
but like we are just on Asia right so
it's kind of a JavaScript conference and
so far you haven't really seen too much
JavaScript which is like if what if you
want to make more complicated things a
multiple Makemake block is micro blocks
it's really good if you want to get
started if you can't want to get
something quick out but as soon as you
you know imagine a thousand lines of
code how that translates into your
thousand blocks it gets really out of
hand and obviously like flexibility is
limited by what kind of blocks you have
access to and all of that
so obviously you would problem what you
use your your skills that you learned in
other languages for programming IOT
devices and there are many ways there's
many ways to program microcontrollers
Arduino is the most known one which you
probably use something like the Arduino
IDE and C++ usually to program your your
your your your microcontrollers there
are all other solutions there are micro
pattern tiny go and all kinds of other
languages that have their tiny versions
and even JavaScript if you want to use
JavaScript or microcontrollers there are
lining of ways to do that
Breno or jitter script all kinds of
other languages there's also a language
a JavaScript runtime called excess like
extra small created by the moddable team
that mozilla cooperates with and the
cool thing about excess is that they
actually created a JavaScript engine
that is able to provide you almost
perfect compatibility with the
JavaScript standard that means the
latest tradition like es6 and and and
further async functions and all the
coolest and newest bells and whistles
that you can imagine you can still use
them on a microcontroller and still fit
your code onto your microcontroller
which is pretty cool so this access
engine my marble actually what they do
is they actually focus on microphone
shoulder devices and that means they
actually provide you with a bunch of
api's that may not even make sense on
the web or not even doesn't really make
sense on a microcontroller in the same
form it makes sense on a map so when the
web you use like WebGL or canvas to
create graphics and animations on the
dom to create you eyes on
microcontrollers that have a few hundred
pixels size this place or even don't
have even displays in your first place
or have to have low-level access and
battery consume then be conscious about
consuming the battery you need a
different API than a fetch API or
something like WebSockets so they
actually provide you access to low-level
Stockyards they actually provide you
access to Bluetooth connectivity because
some chips come with Bluetooth and they
actually provide you a kind of interface
for interacting with graphical displays
all of this in an open source library
that oops that you can use
and there we go
so whatever blamed the German customs
the we wanted to get some more devices
to use so you can actually not just play
with the tiny micro controllers that we
have there but also get some some
connected devices as well you've seen
Mel demoed how you can just use your
micro controller and use a breadboard or
like build attach other devices to some
of the pins and use LEDs or even more
complex devices that you can your
sensors that you could communicate with
I have a device with me and like me to
see if this is enough oh there yeah so
so I have this device with me so if you
look at this I'm gonna just disconnect
it just for a moment if you look at this
device this is nothing really it's
nothing not very different than the
devices you have been using because it
has the same microcontroller chip on it
it's just like kind of plugs into like
this hardware which is like just a
glorified breadboard with a screen on
top so this actually has like a screen
built into the hardware itself to make
it a bit easier to get an out-of-the-box
prototyping experience so let me try yep
Oh God I just messed up all the pins so
that was probably a bad idea to take it
off already go see
oh there we go
so when I plug this back and you can see
that this this is a device that comes so
there's a microchip the same Wi-Fi
control verify connectivity also this
the ESP for DQ device chip is actually
Bluetooth compatible so you also get
bluetooth out of the same same package
and what you can see here let me see if
I can show you is actually color a small
colored screen cool thing about it is
that it actually is a touch screen wow
this is harder than I expected it to be
and so if I there you oh I got it so you
can actually you can actually have
interactions on the screen as well and
control the interactions as well as put
graphics on it so it's pretty cool but
how do you program it right they easy
really is supposed to be a online IDE
very similar to what you just saw in
micro blocks let me see if I can open it
up nope there we go yeah so there is a
working progress online IDE it kind of
sort it looks like Visual Studio code if
you look at it and see Queen Mab it no
but there are there is an online IDE in
progress the problem in the online ID is
that actually uses web usb web USB is
currently only supported by Chrome and
even by Chrome it's barely supported I
couldn't get it working on my Linux
machine for half a day so I kind of give
it up but I still gonna show you so
ideally the online IDE when it gets to a
bit more stable will get you like a kind
of easy startup but also this could be
used if you compile it to like an
electron app you can use it as like a
local device but also you can just write
the JavaScript and use the multiple SDK
which is what I'm going to be using to
flesh the device with with the
JavaScript code
that you want to see on the device so
this is a very simple example that I put
in here just so that you can kind of
have a idea for how do you put code on
the device it's very easy you just use
the same exact JavaScript that you would
be using online it has import statements
it has a few built in modules that you
can get some network connectivity and
some API is that you would normally find
on the web or no GS like a network
socket or something like that that you
can actually use to to make network
connectivity on the device and and the
rest is just plain JavaScript as you
would as you would as you would use it
normally so so I already shown you like
the whoops no no no no where is the
dilemma yeah so I make my face a bit
bigger so I already shown you the like
the draggable demo so I'm gonna do that
I'm actually going to put some more
interesting UI on here not here yeah and
and I'm gonna flush this with the mini
better example so if you actually go to
the multiple open-source repo you will
actually find it tons of examples that
you know it's super easy to get started
so it is flashing to do yeah it's
loading you're loading loading loading
if you have Wi-Fi this is gonna work
eventually we might not have Wi-Fi so at
that point it's not gonna work oh come
on today is not a big have not a good
the demo gods are not really on us
oh yes because this is the better
without the Wi-Fi connection this is
this is better
okay so compiling again yeah it's
flashing their device so it's gonna
restart in a moment the glare is not
helping just a lot
at work did it work come on
not a loading okay that's alright there
we go so are you you're not gonna see
because I'm declare is that we have this
fancy user interface for like a better
kind of thing so you can have like a
better display that you know you can
connect you it connects to the internet
pulls in the data and like shows you
know if you should bring an umbrella
today another interesting thing I wanted
to show you is a showcase a bit more of
the Wi-Fi more of the you know you can
use these like small devices scattered
around your home as like kind of like a
home automation or home control device
and it's flushing again and this is
another application that is also like a
few hundred lines of JavaScript only and
what you're gonna see is is it actually
shows and much nicer interface for your
Wi-Fi connection so I'm gonna click on
one of those a or not
I'm gonna click on it but you're not
gonna see what I'm click on oh there we
go
and you're gonna see it shows like a
little like keyboard so I can input like
the Wi-Fi password or something so you
can build self-contained applications
right into you into the UI of this
device and just one more last one last
more demo that to kind of wrap it all up
the one you can also have applications
that tie straight into them is all of
that things gateway so when you have all
kinds of other devices scattered in your
home you have lights and whatever you
can also and this is what I just
mentioned which you can also build your
own so oops so what you're gonna see is
like a switch that you can just you know
turn on and off like just like you did
with other devices but instead of you
know obviously you would want to do this
like from a central location for your
phone but maybe you want to have like
like a tiny control panels you know in
your house as well so people who don't
have access to the Gateway directly you
can expose functionality your smart home
why these tiny small tablet displays the
one of the biggest appeal of the ESP
devices so this this chip this micro
controller the powers the this this
whole build up is there inexpensiveness
the esp8266 the some other devices you
have been using is literally a few
dollars if your order is quantity and
the ESP for the cue the one that has
Bluetooth support and which is a bit
faster and newer it's just a few more
dollars this whole screen assembly is
being sold for about $20 US dollars that
is so you could imagine that it wouldn't
bring by the bank if you wanted to
scatter some of these smart controllers
or devices around your home and you
could
you could program them whatever you
would like to do again just as we had
anything else in the muscle of F thanks
Frank this is not you're not bound by
you know the crappy software and apps
that ship ships with all the devices
that you have at home you can do you can
make your own and you can make sure it's
open-source you can use somebody else's
you can customize your own experiences
instead of having to you know pull your
hair out trying to set up a smart camera
that you just paid $200 for so yeah so
just to wrap yeah you don't really want
to see my face too much just to wrap
this all up you can use the Mozilla
gateway as the kind of like a private
source for or like a private you know
center of your home automation devices
and you can use like all kinds of
devices proprietary ones that you bought
off there is a lot of add-ons so you can
tie those into your smart net but also
build your own devices wherever you want
to do some simple like switches and and
stuff that you just want to kind of you
know just put together quickly or if you
want to build more elaborate like
control devices and sensors right into
the rooms or or do the space itself you
can also do that with JavaScript without
having to learn or you know worry about
C++ and you know memory segmentation
faults and all kinds of other problems
as soon as you can set up you know your
computer to kind of accept the USB
connection which seems to be probably
the hardest part of the whole thing okay
I think we are done right
yeah if if you have any questions we are
we are here still we're gonna be
starting to set up for inferno next
group but feel free to ask questions
thank you for joining
[Applause]